comme je vous l'avais annoncé après
l'examen des crédits du patrimoine pour
l'année 2023 nous recevons ce matin
Guillaume Poitrinal et Célia Véro
respectivement président et directrice
générale de la Fondation du patrimoine
afin de faire un point avec eux sur la
situation de leur établissement et plus
globalement sur les tâches général de
notre patrimoine monsieur le Président
Madame la Directrice générale nous
sommes ravis de vous accueillir une
nouvelle fois parmi nous notre
commission est comme vous le savez très
attaché à la à la préservation du
patrimoine nous considérons que sa
conservation et sa transmission de ses
édifices constituent un véritable enjeu
pour nos territoires d'un point de vue
culturel mais aussi économique
touristique sociale et j'ajouterai même
écologique dans la réhabilitation du
patrimoine pourrait être un moyen de
limiter les émissions de gaz à effet de
serre liés aux constructions nouvelles
l'action de votre fondation est
évidemment fondamentale dans la
préservation du patrimoine en
particulier du patrimoine non protégé
qui ne bénéficie d'aucun soutien de la
part de l'État elle est un partenaire
d'un grand nombre de collectivités
territoriales pour la restauration de
leur patrimoine ce n'est pas un hasard
si le législateur a souhaité conforter
ses moyens d'action en adoptant en 2021
une loi visant à moderniser ces outils
et sa gouvernance sur l'initiative de
notre colis notre collègue Dominique
Verrien c'est bien que son action est
reconnue et doit absolument être
poursuivi la création de la mission Bern
en 2017 et l'incendie de la cathédrale
Notre-Dame de Paris en 2019 ont donné à
votre établissement une ampleur nouvelle
en faisant de lui l'un des l'une des
principales institutions de référence en
matière de sauvegarde du patrimoine
nous serions évidemment très désireux
que nous donniez des éléments de bilan
sur ces différents sujets nous sommes
conscients que le secteur du patrimoine
a été très affecté par la crise
sanitaire et continue à en ressentir
certains effets malgré le plan de
relance dans ce contexte qu'elle est la
situation de la Fondation quelles sont
les difficultés auxquelles vous devez
encore faire face surtout quels sont vos
ambitions pour les années à venir les
récents travaux de notre commission sur
les questions liées à la préservation du
patrimoine montre que les chantiers sont
nombreux je pense par exemple au rapport
de nos collègues Anne Ventalon et Pierre
ouzouyas sur le patrimoine religieux qui
vous inspirait je crois la création d'un
prix décerné des bonnes pratiques en
matière d'usage partagée ou de
reconversion d'édifices religieux je
pense aussi aux menaces que fait peser
la transition écologique et énergétique
si elle n'est pas correctement articulée
avec les impératifs de préservation du
patrimoine
c'est un point sur lequel notre collègue
notre rapporteur Sabine Drexler nous a
alerté il y a plusieurs reprises et
notamment dans le cadre de son avis
budgétaire et qui nécessite que tous les
acteurs du patrimoine se mobilisent
monsieur le Président de laisser la
parole pour une présentation liminaire
et puis après bien sûr nous aurons les
uns et les autres des questions à vous
poser
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président je
suis ravi d'être là avec avec Célia car
nous sommes ici dans une institution qui
a toujours soutenu la Fondation du
Patrimoine depuis sa création en 1996
c'est à la fois une jeune et une vieille
institution le succès récent que vous
avez vu de la Fondation du patrimoine
qui a multiplié par 3 son budget depuis
2017 ce succès illustre à la fois la
qualité du travail de Célia et de nos
bénévoles mais aussi l'urgence à
laquelle nous sommes confrontés
aujourd'hui vis-à-vis de la dégradation
du du patrimoine depuis 25 ans nous
avons sauvé 35000 sites patrimoniaux
c'est-à-dire en fait un site à peu près
tous les 5 km en France en moyenne c'est
donc considérable nous sommes intervenus
dans plus de 18000 communes donc plus
plus d'une commune sur deux a vu la
Fondation du Patrimoine s'intéresser à
un moulin un théâtre un pigeonnier à une
église à un pont et ce qui a permis de
fédérer les énergies
l'idée toute simple du début est une
idée à mon avis très d'actualité elle
consiste à dire on ne peut pas tout
attendre de l'État il faut que les
énergies locales se mobilisent il faut
que la philanthropie puisse jouer un
rôle et quand ces énergies locales se
mobilisent quand nos bénévoles
organisent des collectes anime des
collectes et bien tout d'un coup à la
fois nous recevons de l'argent dans les
souscriptions nous recevons des mécénats
d'entreprises nous intéressons les
collectivités locales les départements
les régions et évidemment nous faisons
la promotion dans la presse quotidienne
régionale et à travers tous les médias
de ces opérations de sauvetage à titre
liminaire je voudrais dire que dans ce
pays qui aime bien la division avec le
football
le patrimoine c'est
œcuménique c'est à dire
c'est une cause dans laquelle il y a peu
de débats politiques il y a peu de
partis politiques qui s'opposent à la
préservation du patrimoine et à la
transmission de l'immense héritage que
nous avons reçu de nos de nos
grands-parents et de nos ancêtres et qui
font la différence entre la France et
beaucoup de pays la France est né d'une
puissance agricole et donc elle a des
villages absolument magnifiques partout
partout en France et et il convient de
de s'y intéresser pour vous donner un
ordre d'idée de ce que nous avons
aujourd'hui dans ce grand hôpital qui
est la Fondation du Patrimoine
aujourd'hui en souscription nous avons
2178 projets ce matin sur le sur le
compteur parmi lesquels mille églises
150 châteaux 30 ponts 27 moulins 17
musées 20 maisons d'artistes 13 théâtre
et après je vous épargne les petits
ponts les petits chemins etc donc et
locomotive les avions exceptionnels les
bateaux enfin
les aérostrains voilà
nous avons absolument tout ce que la
France dispose de patrimoine un peu
exceptionnel et avec un seul objectif
pouvoir le transmettre et le valoriser
quand je dis valoriser c'est important
parce que il n'y a pas de meilleur
assurance pour la conservation du
patrimoine que de lui redonner un usage
alors vous allez me dire cet usage ça
peut être ça peut être la visite oui
certes ça peut être la visite mais ça
peut être aussi
une église transformée en salle des
fêtes ça peut être alors évidemment
après des affectations je ne veux pas
ici choquer choqué personne nous ne
sommes nous militons pas pour la
fermeture des églises nous militons pour
que il y ait un usage sur sur ces
bâtiments qui sont souvent oubliés
désaffectés évidemment ça peut être
aussi du le développement économique on
n'a pas de problème à ce que y est un
peu de commerce des services publics qui
puissent revenir à l'intérieur de ce
patrimoine on a aussi beaucoup de de
d'usages qui sont réapparus je pense à
un pont Eiffel magnifique qui
aujourd'hui sur lequel il y a un GR un
chemin de grande randonnée qui alors que
ce pont avait été fermé pendant plus de
plus de 30 ans
voilà donc on est on est très attentif à
cette question de je dirais d'usage de
destination quand un maire vient nous
voir avec un projet de rénovation d'un
théâtre à l'italienne 1850 la première
chose la première question qu'on pose
c'est évidemment on va se mettre au
boulot mais qu'est-ce qui peut y avoir
comme programmation dans ce théâtre
aujourd'hui qui peut s'en occuper et
très souvent on arrive sur la question
du bénévolat et le bénévolat c'est la
grande ressource sans nos 850 bénévoles
répartis sur tout le territoire
c'est-à-dire une délégation
départementale par département
une délégation régionale par région et
plutôt les anciennes régions parce que
les nouvelles régions ne nous
conviennent pas tellement elles sont
considérables par leur importance je
rappelle que la région
nouvelle-aquitaine est grande comme
l’autriche et qu'évidemment je ne peux
pas demander un délégué régional basé à
Bordeaux d'être l'après-midi à
Châtellerault et le soir même dans au
fond du Pays Basque c'est strictement
impossible en tout ça en passant par le
plateau des Millevaches pour ceux qui
connaissent la géographie donc c'est
c'est tout à fait tout à fait saugrenu
donc nous sommes restés dans ce
dispositif et c'est bien cette armée de
bénévoles que nous souhaitons vous
m'avez parlé tout à l'heure de nos
ambitions nous sommes 850 bénévoles nos
amis anglais ont 30000 bénévoles dans le
National Trust vous voyez le chemin qui
nous sépare de l'exemple anglais avec
Célia nous sommes fixés l'objectif de
doubler le nombre de bénévoles dans les
trois ans qui viennent de la même façon
que nous étions fixé l'objectif de
tripler le budget de la Fondation depuis
depuis 4 ans et
nous avons nous avons réussi ce pari
donc le gros effort qui va venir
maintenant c'est pour nous d'intéresser
les bénévoles bénévoles à la fois
retraités évidemment c'est un réservoir
qu'on préserve qu'on chouchoute mais
aussi des bénévoles actifs qui peuvent
non pas donner quatre ou cinq jours on a
des retraités qui travaillent à temps
plein ils travaillent qui disent je
travaille plus pour la Fondation que du
temps de mon ancien employeur donc
mais aussi mais aussi mais aussi des
bénévoles qui nous apportent des
compétences une heure une heure deux
heures par semaine sur une thématique
particulière la présence sur les réseaux
sociaux
l'accompagnement de projet la levée de
fonds la petite collecte je rappelle que
sur nos ressources en fait nous avons
différentes ressources alors président
info pour être très direct la première
une des premières ressources à l'époque
beaucoup moins maintenant de la
Fondation du Patrimoine sont les
fameuses successions en déshérence donc
aujourd'hui c'est à peu près 6
8 millions d'euros c'est remonté un
petit peu les succession des errance
donc les domaines nous verrent 8
millions d'euros des succession des
différences qui permettent de couvrir
très largement nos délégations nos
bureaux parce que on a des bureaux et
nos
75 salariés 75 salariés si j'ai si j'ai
le bon chiffre à jour mais ensuite nous
travaillons beaucoup avec de la de la du
petit don de la petite collecte donc les
fameuses 2700 souscription ouverte sur
notre site internet en permanence c'est
ce que les Américains appelleraient du
crowdfunding mais c'est de la
souscription populaire nous avons des
mécénats avec les entreprises club de
Mécène dans les régions grandes
opérations de mécénat et je vais y
revenir tout à l'heure parce que j'ai
une demande à vous faire de modification
législatives sur ce sur ce sujet grand
mécène donc avec les avec total avec la
maison d'assaut enfin la famille
d'assaut plus exactement avec AXA avec
AG2R LA MONDIALE avec jessina donc de
grandes opérations et puis
le loto du patrimoine le loto du
patrimoine est une est une merveilleuse
invention en fait c'est une coopération
c'est une association entre la
personnalité très reconnue et très
appréciée de de Stéphane Bern et puis
nos bénévoles qui avec les Dracs
d'ailleurs avec le ministère de la
Culture vont
identifier ces projets et puis les
sélectionner pour ressortir un projet
par département et un projet par région
avec également l'aide de la Française
des jeux qui qui nous aide et qui
complémente d'ailleurs sont son soutien
par une opération de mécénat qui vient
qui vient s'inscrire en parallèle en
fait de ces de ces tirages de loto qui
sont très très populaires et qui
permettent de mettre en lumière à chaque
fois ce nos opérations de sauvetage
autre axe pour pour l'avenir le
patrimoine naturel 62000 hectares de
forêts qui sont partis en fumée nous
avons été là comme nous l'avions été
d'ailleurs pour l'incendie de Notre-Dame
nous avons été là pour répondre à
travers une souscription pour replanter
ces forêts le la Fondation du Patrimoine
c'est évidemment le bâti c'est
évidemment des objets des moyens de
transport c'est aussi le patrimoine
naturel nous intervenons très souvent à
l'appui d'opération je peux vous donner
un exemple dans le marais poitevin nous
sommes ici pour pour replanter les
petits arbres têtard qui sont menacés
par le réchauffement climatique et un
insecte qui vient qui vient les faire
mourir à un champignon plus exactement
plus précisément on est intervenu sur le
Canal du Midi on intervient dans des
dans des marais pour préserver des
marées qui sont menacés et on a de plus
en plus de demandes sur le thème du
patrimoine naturel c'est donc un sujet
sur lequel nous allons très clairement
[Musique]
œuvré dans les années les années qui
viennent alors vous m'avez demandé deux
propositions je suis pas venu avec les
textes Célia pourrait vous voulez vous
les rédiger dans l'après-midi si vous le
souhaitez
la première c'est que nous avons
nous sommes clairement
victimes vis-à-vis des grands des grands
mécènes de cette limitation à 2 millions
d'euros de la déduction à 60% des des
mécénats des grandes entreprises cette
cette limitation elle a eu comme origine
des polémiques sur des fondations
d'entreprises qui portaient le nom des
entreprises elles-mêmes et et on peut
parfois comprendre cette polémique même
si on n'a pas vocation à y participer
pour ce qui s'agit des fondations
reconnues d'utilité publique qui sont
placées comme nous sous des tutelles
ministériels et qui ne portent pas le
nom d'entreprise privée je pense que il
conviendrait de revenir à l'ancien
système c'est à dire supprimer ce
plafonnement à 2 millions dès 60% de
déduction je pense que ça ne coûterait
absolument rien à Bercy parce que je
vous rappelle en tout cas pour ceux qui
nous concerne qu'à chaque fois que nous
nous envoyons 100 euros pour des travaux
il y a généralement 20% de TVA pour
commencer et sans compter les impôts de
production et les impôts sur les
sociétés des artisans qui bénéficient
enfin qui bénéficient qui sont nos
contreparties pour la rénovation de ces
bâtiments donc quand on quand on aide la
Fondation du Patrimoine on aide d'abord
les finances de Bercy il faut le
reconnaître et donc je trouverai assez
naturel que nous n'ayons plus cette
limite à 2 millions d'euros pour des
très grands groupes qui peuvent donner
bien davantage et qui se sont vus
limiter maintenant dans leur capacité
d'être philanthrope si quand même est un
peu incombe et puis la deuxième le
deuxième sujet que je voulais apporter
ici c'est un sujet qui concerne un effet
grosse question de la rénovation
thermique oui il faut rénover nos
bâtiments mais rénover des bâtiments à
caractère patrimonial c'est éminemment
plus cher que de rénover des bâtiments
qui sont plus modernes et c'est d'autant
plus cher évidemment on a très souvent
des architectes des bâtiments de France
et qui surveillent que on met pas des
fenêtres des huisseries en plexiglas et
combien de pas faire une doublure par
l'extérieur de la façade avec du crépi
donc
ça coûte plus cher ça coûte plus cher et
à mon avis une des solutions serait de
pouvoir étendre le champ du label de la
Fondation du Patrimoine vous savez que
le label est notre deuxième outil
d'intervention nous délivrons des labels
qui donnent qui permettent aux
bénéficiaires de label de défiscaliser
50% des dépenses qu'ils font mais ce
label qui est très encadré il est
encadré parce que on va rechercher les
avis des ABS évidemment c'est juste sur
du patrimonial c'est-à-dire des objets
non classés d'intérêt patrimonial
visible de la voie publique ce label ne
concerne que des travaux de visibilité
extérieure c'est-à-dire des huisseries
vu de l'extérieur des toitures vu de
l'extérieur et ça or nous très
honnêtement les opérations de rénovation
on souhaite plutôt qu'elles aient lieu à
l'intérieur c'est à dire que le le
doublage il est vraiment lieu à
l'intérieur et donc on vous propose pour
ce cas particulier
de des labels des bénéficiaires de label
que les opérations d'isolation puissent
rentrer très clairement à l'intérieur de
ce label je pense que c'est un petit
effort mais cet effort il est nécessaire
pour permettre l'isolation de de ce
petit patrimoine voilà c'était une
c'était deux suggestions en tout cas
pour clore mon propos en attendant vos
questions
merci monsieur le Président avant de
donner à parole à mes collègues juste un
point peut-être sur Notre-Dame sur la
rénovation de Notre-Dame suite à son
incendie on sait que la collecte de dons
a été très importante à 850 millions
d'euros les travaux sont en train de
sont en cours de réalisation ont bien
entendu quel est votre point de vue à la
fois sur la mobilisation forte et puis
sur l'utilisation des fonds ainsi
collectés
Notre-Dame est une opération formidable
de c'est un grand soulèvement populaire
et pour la première fois dans notre pays
en fait une opération de sauvetage
patrimonial va être 100% financé par du
mécénat et des dons et la collecte
Notre-Dame qui nous a beaucoup occupé
puisque la Fondation si j'exclus les
donations dites des milliardaires
français la Fondation du Patrimoine a
collecté les deux tiers avec ses 232
millions à collecter les deux tiers des
dons à la fois en nombre et en volume
donc la grande collecte populaire vous
avez probablement vous connaissez dans
votre entourage et gens qui ont donné à
cette grande collecte populaire on a
reçu des dons d'ailleurs du monde entier
pour Notre-Dame la Grande collecte
populaire est largement arrivée à la
Fondation du Patrimoine ce qui nous
donne une responsabilité particulière
j'ai regretté et je continue de
regretter que la Fondation est que les
fondations en général aient été écartées
de la gouvernance de l'établissement
public et que la loi n'est pas prévue
qu'il y ait une représentation de ces
donateurs qui finalement qu'ils soient
grandes entreprises ou particulier vont
permettre cette magnifique rénovation
le deuxième élément c'est que dans les
derniers budgets qui qui apparaissent
nous sommes ce que nous avions dit
d'ailleurs très tôt et nous avions été
très critiqués nous sommes en excédent
de la collecte par rapport aux besoins
qui était je le répète de la collecte
nationale qui s'appelait rebâtir
Notre-Dame c'est-à-dire par rapport aux
besoins de la reconstruction et donc va
s'engager inévitablement un débat
puisque tout cela repose quand même sur
une loi qui s'appelle la loi Notre-Dame
que vous avez débattu dans ce dans votre
hémicycle sur ce que nous allons faire
de ce surplus surplus si il s'agirait
pas pour nous et je pense pas que ce
soit l'intention de l'État que l'État
s'enrichisse sur l'opération Notre-Dame
il faut savoir que l'État avait prévu 60
millions de participation avant
l'incendie à la rénovation de Notre-Dame
sur 10 ans il avait prévu d'ailleurs
d'abonder à la collecte de la Fondation
Notre-Dame 1 euro pour un euro donc je
sais pas s'il compte abonder 800
millions d'euros mais de toute façon il
n'y a pas besoin de rajouter 800
millions d'euros dans dans ce trésor de
guerre il est très largement suffisant
mais en tout cas il ne conviendrait pas
que l'État s'épargne de l'effort et de
son devoir vis-à-vis de Notre-Dame
l'état propriétaire il a eu déjà la
chance d'avoir des mécènes et des
donateurs qui viennent finalement
réparer les dégâts de l'incendie je
pense que il faut que tous ensemble on
doit on soit déterminé dans à partir de
maintenant une vision je dirais en toute
transparence des vrais besoins de
Notre-Dame faire la différence entre ce
qui relève de l'incendie et ce qui
relève puisque là aujourd'hui on
commence à arriver des collectes du
confort de la visite aujourd'hui on nous
demande de participer à l'aménagement
des sorties de secours de la sacristie à
l'aménagement de la circulation
dans les tours on nous propose de
participer à du mobilier on nous propose
qui sont très certainement des des
enjeux tout à fait respectables mais qui
n'ont rien à voir avec l'intention de
nos donateurs et qui à l'origine ont
répondu à une ambition c'est-à-dire
reconstruire ce qui a été donc nous
disons chacun doit aujourd'hui avoir ces
responsabilités et nous souhaitons
engager le débat avec la ministre de de
la culture et avec l'établissement
public sur la destination de ce surplus
évidemment comme je vous l'ai dit en
matière de patrimoine il y a urgence la
destination se surplus elle relève
principalement de mécénats d'entreprise
je rappelle que la petite collecte un
notre premier segment de collecte nos
premiers 50 millions qui se qui relève
plus d'une souscription d'ailleurs que
d'opération de mécénat c'est l'argent
qui nous est arrivé directement
cet argent a déjà été engagé donc il ne
nous reste aujourd'hui à engager que de
l'argent issu de mécénat les mécénats se
sont des contrats de droits privés entre
la Fondation du Patrimoine et ses
mécènes or c'est mécénat sont très
clairement pour la plupart circonscrit
au besoin de reconstruction de la
cathédrale donc si on devait utiliser
cette ressource pour d'autres besoins il
conviendrait évidemment
d'ouvrir le dialogue avec cette
vingtaine de grandes entreprises ou
cette trentaine de grandes entreprises
qui restent qui nous restent à verser
qui qui doivent encore verser les fonds
voilà un petit point président sur la
sur Notre-Dame merci mais c'était un
point important je pense que nous y
reviendrons à travers vos questions je
donne la parole à Sabine Drexler qui est
rapporteur
des crédits patrimoine
merci
qui nous donne de l'espoir je voudrais
vous féliciter aussi pour l'ensemble de
vos actions pour vos initiatives pour
les partenariats aussi que vous mettez
en oeuvre dans les territoires alors on
connaît les difficultés auxquelles
doivent faire face aujourd'hui les
communes et les particuliers je pense
notamment au coût de l'énergie et des
matières premières qui amènent de
nombreuses collectivités à devoir
renoncer ou surseoir leur projet de
rénovation ou d'entretien du patrimoine
faute de moyens financés suffisants et
de pouvoir anticiper l'avenir dans le
même temps la loi climat est résilience
impose aux propriétaires privés ou
publics de réaliser des travaux
d'isolation faute de pouvoir sous peu
louer leurs biens ou les vendre alors
juste valeur de nombreux propriétaires
bailleurs ne sont pas on le sait on
mesure de financer les travaux attendus
c'est bien seront délaissés faute de
pouvoir être loué puis ensuite céder au
prix du terrain un phénomène qui va
s'accélérer on le sait avec la mise en
oeuvre du zan
d'autres encore en toute bonne foi et
parce que le DPE actuel ne tient aucun
compte des qualités thermiques
spécifiques au bâti anciens vont
s'acceler sans ingénierie et sans mise
en garde particulière à des travaux
d'isolation à la merci de professionnels
du polystyrène qui avec le soutien
financier de l'État étouffront petit à
petit les particularités architecturales
de nos régions françaises
alors mes questions alors quel impact à
votre avis auront les attendus de la loi
climat et résilience sur le patrimoine
bâti de notre pays en particulier sur
celui d'avant 1948 je pense notamment
aux maisons à pans de bois aux Maisons
Pierre qui ne bénéficient d'aucune
mesure de protection ces mesures qui
concentrent justement toute l'attention
de la Fondation du Patrimoine et de la
mission Berne quels sont le cas échéant
les actions de la Fondation dans ce
domaine et dans quelle mesure certains
de vos outils pourraient-ils être
mobilisés pour faciliter cette
transition énergétique d'une manière
respectueuse de ce patrimoine merci
je vais vous laisser répondre à ça
merci beaucoup une grande partie de la
réponse tient dans votre question
c'est à dire qu'en effet c'est un vrai
sujet et c'est un sujet auquel on va
devoir tous
faire face
je pense que le label est une des
réponses je vous en ai donné vraiment un
élément mais le label nous permet
également de mobiliser des subventions
c'est un bon outil c'est un outil qui
est en place il permet il d'abord il est
il est assez efficace du point de vue de
la de sa fonctionnalité puisque une fois
encore ce sont nos bénévoles alors en
rapport avec avec les ABS avec les drags
etc mais ce sont nos bénévoles qui qui
interviennent qui instruisent le dossier
donc les frais d'instruction de dossier
sont très modestes et donc ils sont à
l'échelle de ce dont on parle parce que
si on commence à mettre des choses
compliquées dans derrière ce type de de
projet ça de c'est évidemment assez
embêtant et pénalisant nous pouvons
mobiliser des
des subventions nous avons d'ailleurs
des accords Célia va pouvoir vous en
parler nous avons des accords avec des
municipalités avec des départements pour
venir quand il y a un label à l'appui
d'une opération d'amélioration de
sauvetage patrimonial il faut juste que
nous considérions tous ensemble quand
des faits cette efficience énergétique
fait partie du Chant de la préservation
du du patrimoine et vous l'avez très
bien dit pour une simple et bonne raison
c'est que s'il ne peut plus y avoir
d'usage parce que l'énergie est trop
cher mais indépendamment de la question
si on peut louer ou pas loué mais
l'énergie va coûter demain tellement
cher que si on peut plus chauffer
évidemment ces bâtiments ils vont tomber
en déshérence il faut pas se raconter
d'histoires là-dessus ils vont tomber en
déshérence donc indépendamment de
favoris c'est pas un sujet ils vont
tomber en essence donc il faut
absolument isoler ces bâtiments du du
patrimoine il faut le faire dans le
respect on sait le faire dans le respect
du patrimoine dans le respect de ces
façades magnifiques que vous avez évoqué
tu veux ajouter quelque chose
oui effectivement Guillaume Poitrinal a
évoqué le fait que le label est un
support intéressant à une action sur le
patrimoine ancien non protégé qui est
celui des propriétaires privés pour
parler concrètement ce sont des maisons
de village ou des maisons rurales qui
forment le décor de la France et son
attractivité touristique et le confort
de vie des habitants alors d'une part
parce qu'effectivement on peut au
travers de partenariats avec des
collectivités
mobiliser des subventions qui vont
permettre
d'accorder aux propriétaires une aide
tous les propriétaires ne sont pas très
imposables donc le fait qu'on leur donne
une aide pour les travaux est
intéressantes
dans le système fiscal actuel lorsque
c'est subventions permettent d'atteindre
un seuil de 20% en fait ça déclenche une
aide fiscale plus importante et donc ça
justement ça ça rend le dispositif plus
attractif pour des propriétaires peu
imposables mais aussi quelque chose
qu'on ne sait pas encore c'est que le
support du label permet aussi de
mobiliser du mécénat
sert des dons particuliers ou des dons
d'entreprises pour des travaux sur des
propriétés privées alors c'est encore
peu fréquent parce qu'on imagine
aujourd'hui mal on se dit bon est-ce que
des grandes entreprises vont vouloir
financer des travaux sur des petites
propriétés mais pourquoi pas je dirais
parce que si ça comporte si ça contribue
à l'embellissement urbain au cadre de
nos villages et puis peut-être à des
objectifs climatiques pourquoi pas
recevoir des enveloppes de mécénat on le
fait déjà avec un grand mécène
aujourd'hui donc pourquoi pas recevoir
des enveloppes de mécénat qu'on
distribuerait aussi à des petits projets
partout en France donc ça c'est le
premier intérêt le deuxième intérêt
c'est que ça nous permet de faire des
travaux qui sont de qualité patrimoniale
sans rechercher non plus l'excès ou
l'absolutisme on est sur du patrimoine
non protégé donc on va faire des
compromis entre les moyens du
propriétaire les enjeux du patrimoine et
puis maintenant ceux de la rénovation
thermique et le défi ça va être donc
d'intégrer à une logique qui aujourd'hui
très patrimoniale les enjeux nous on le
fait déjà sur des bâtiments qui sont des
sortes de prototypes ou démonstrateurs
qui sont aujourd'hui plutôt des
bâtiments publics par exemple des
maisons de parc naturel régionaux
dans plusieurs endroits de France par
exemple dans le Boulonnais ou
dans d'autres régions le Parc Naturel
Régional décide de restaurer son siège
qui est un bâtiment patrimonial pour
atteindre une qualité validée par les
ABS et en même temps BBC donc avec ces
démonstrateurs on peut prouver que c'est
possible on sait qu'il y a un surcoût
mais ensuite on brûlera le répliquer sur
toutes les maisons de la région qui sont
faites dans les mêmes matériaux et donc
c'est ce défi c'est de passer à
l'échelle de passer de prototypes à un
déploiement auprès de tous ces
propriétaires qui viennent nous voir
pour avoir des labels et leur proposer
des solutions pour l'intérieur parce que
à l'intérieur non plus on peut pas faire
n'importe quoi une maison ancienne c'est
avant tout un objet qui est durable dans
le temps et elle a été construite il y a
longtemps autant ne pas reconstruire sur
des emprises au sol qui sont nouvelles
autant ne pas faire venir des matériaux
avoir des impacts carbone
supplémentaires autant utiliser le
patrimoine existant mais il faut
respecter ses qualités intrinsèques un
bâtiment tient il est fait pour être
respirant donc on peut mettre certains
matériaux on peut pas mettre n'importe
quoi et aujourd'hui comme les filières
professionnelles sont pas très
construites c'est vrai que les artisans
plutôt l'habitude de faire de la
rénovation standard il faut mettre de
l'argent pour susciter ces entreprises
et ses qualifications qui vont permettre
de déployer à une très grande échelle
puisque finalement on parle de tout
notre patrimoine ancien toutes nos
maisons anciennes c'est des millions de
bâtiments
merci je vais regrouper les questions
comme ça en commençant par Sonia de la
pauvreté
[Musique]
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
Madame la Directrice générale je me
joins à ma collègue Sabine Sabine pour
vous remercier de votre action dans dans
les territoires et moi dans le calvatos
j'en suis particulièrement heureuse
alors plusieurs questions d'abord
vous avez un peu un rôle de de veilleur
du patrimoine et des paysages dans les
territoires parce que vous êtes présents
quasi partout
et du coup on voit bien que les
politiques de prise en charge du
patrimoine ont un petit sujet
d'organisation les maires déplore des
problématiques d'assistance à maîtrise
d'ouvrage des problématiques pour monter
les dossiers bouclés le dossier
financier les dossiers techniques
trouver les bons les bonnes références
d'intervention
en matière d'entreprise pour pour la
mise en œuvre des chantiers et on voit
bien que quand le patrimoine n'est pas
classé c'est un tout petit peu plus
compliqué et c'est ajouter à cela cette
cette question du DPE qui a amené
encore plus de la difficulté pour
trouver le bon interlocuteur au bon prix
avec la bonne maquette et le bon projet
je suis un package mais c'est un peu ça
et donc dans un rapport précédent nous
avions mis
en avant la question de la nécessité
d'un guichet unique départemental je
voudrais connaître votre point de vue
sur ce sujet cette histoire du guichet
unique c'est pas une histoire uniquement
de de
savoir qui aura le qui aura la main sur
ce guichet le sujet c'est plutôt d'avoir
tout le monde autour de la table pour
éviter
l'incontournable tourner des popotes
avant de pouvoir boucler quelque chose
et ça peut durer des fois 5 à 6 ans et
puis il peut y avoir une erreur de dépôt
de dossier qui fait que c'est tout
compromis et on ne peut pas finalement
mettre à jour le patrimoine donc
vraiment cette question là me
semble-t-il était essent et on voit bien
que le loto du patrimoine s'est rajouté
enfin tout ça se rajoute petit à petit
et ça devient confus pour les
propriétaires ma deuxième question porte
sur le rôle du ministère et la place que
tient le patrimoine dans le ministère
parce que on voit bien les derniers lois
que ce soit en matière d'éolien en
matière de photovoltaïque ou en matière
de de
DPE et de mise aux normes énergétique à
pas complètement on pas complètement mis
dans leurs écrans radars le patrimoine
parce que probablement il n'a pas été
complètement mis dans les écrans radars
des priorités à l'instar des autres et
donc voilà ma question porte sur le rôle
du ministère et comment vous voyez de la
culture bien de la culture voilà et
pensez-vous que il est nécessaire que
que ce rôle là soit mieux défendu et par
quel vois et moyen puisque Stéphane Bern
ne peut pas lui seul incarner le
ministère de la culture et les
politiques publiques en matière de
patrimoine comme d'ailleurs la Fondation
du Patrimoine du reste et puis ma
dernière question porte sur les
programmes actions cœur de ville et
petite ville de demain je sais que vous
êtes très engagés sur ces sujets là
il ne reste pas moins que ça reste sur
une partie quand même limite de de
communes à l'échelle du territoire mais
est-ce que quel bilan vous en tirez pas
en matière de redynamisation pour le
coup mais quand même en matière de
vitalité patrimoniale et de mise en
valeur du patrimoine et est-ce que vous
pensez que les outils qui ont été mis en
oeuvre dans ce cadre-là pour être étendu
de façon
utile à d'autres communes qui ne
relèvent pas du programme mais qui
pourraient très légitimement relever je
vous remercie
je vais prendre toutes les questions ça
sera peut-être plus simple comme ça vous
aurez des réponses sans doute groupées à
faire pierre ouzouillas
[Musique]
merci monsieur le Président merci
beaucoup pour pour votre présentation
vos commentaires vous vous avez cité
l'excellent rapport rendu par ma
collègue Anne Ventalon qui m'a associé à
ce travail exemplaire je
voulais juste rappeler un point de
définition nous avons parlé d'usage
partagé mais sans désaffectation des
lieux de culte c'est à dire qu'il faut
absolument maintenir quand c'est
possible le culte mais trouver des
usages partagés qui permettent de
valoriser le bâtiment sur la
problématique de la reconversion du bâti
ancien vous avez mille fois raison et je
crois qu'il faut faire façon très forte
les monuments anciens c'est des
logements bas carbone par destination
puisqu'ils ont été construits à une
époque où la sobriété énergétique était
une règle de vie c'est c'est très
récemment que nous avons construit en
oubliant ces impératifs énergétiques
donc aujourd'hui les rendre coupables de
de d'un ralentissement des efforts pour
changer notre consommation d'énergie
c'est un paradoxe historique que je ne
comprends pas et qu'il faut renverser
par ailleurs vous l'avez dit très
justement quand on détruit un monument
historique on détruit un pull carbone
c'est comme purger une tourbière c'est
des monuments c'est des matériaux
organiques qui étaient piégés et qui
repartent dans la nature donc ça je
crois qu'il faut le il faut le dire
parce que il y a pas une prise de
conscience très claire aujourd'hui et y
compris au sein du gouvernement sur sur
le fait que le patrimoine ne peut pas
être considéré comme un obstacle à la
décarbonation de de nos sociétés c'est
c'est quelque chose de tout à fait
fondamental et on le voit bien en ce
moment à l'Assemblée nationale le point
de vue très consensuel qui a été
développé grâce à l'action de cette
commission et bah tu en prêches par par
d'autres d'autres idées sur
je reprends le propos de Sonia de la
provoeté quand j'étais jeune
conservateur au ministère de la Culture
nous avons beaucoup travaillé sur la
protection du troisième type aujourd'hui
par la délivrance de votre label vous
mettez en oeuvre finalement cette
protection du troisième type c'est à
dire quelque chose qui permet de
distinguer un bâti qui n'est pas du
classement qui n'est pas une inscription
qui est autre chose mais qui ouvre des
droits fiscaux environnementaux
etc et je pense que c'est c'est sans
doute un des moyens aujourd'hui de
remettre un peu d'initiative nationale
dans dans une gestion du patrimoine non
inscrit pour lequel le directeur du
patrimoine nous a dit lui-même qui ne
pouvait plus rien
on l'a on l'a entendu avec Anne Ventalon
l'entretien a duré un quart d'heure nous
a dit patrimoine
non inscrit non classé oubliez l'état
voilà c'était fini ce qui fait que dans
dans les préconisations de de notre
rapport il nous a semblé que il fallait
acter le fait que il y a aujourd'hui une
décentralisation de facto du patrimoine
non inscrit plutôt vers le département
et à ce titre c'est ma question c'est
comment vous pourriez mieux travailler
avec les ciao et est-ce que par exemple
il serait pas intéressant de faire que
la Fondation du Patrimoine puisse être
intégrée de droit dans le fonctionnement
des ce parce que c'est sans doute
l'échelon de proximité le plus le plus
intéressant ce qui ce qui nous revient
ce qui nous revient du terrain c'est que
il y a beaucoup de demandes de la belle
Fondation du Patrimoine que les ABS
n'ont pas toujours la possibilité
matérielle de gérer
il y a des blocages alors qu'ils sont
très variables suivant les régions mais
il y a des régions où malheureusement
aujourd'hui les ABF sont dans
l'incapacité de pouvoir donner leur avis
sur votre label donc là il y a aussi un
ralentissement donc il y a une
structuration à trouver entre le
désengagement de l'État ministère de la
Culture ce que vous faites et qui est
tout à fait fondamental et la nécessaire
relation avec les niveaux de
décentralisation de facto du patrimoine
donc là c'est merci monsieur le
Président Céline Boulley sportif
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Président Madame la Directrice Générale
j'avais deux questions d'abord avant de
vous faire une petite remarque vous avez
dit que la première la petite collecte
était le premier segment de collecte
pour votre fondation je voulais
simplement
voir ça marche oui non ça marche pas je
voulais simplement savoir si vous aviez
des craintes par rapport aux difficultés
liées au pouvoir d'achat et si vous
pensiez que ce premier segment qui est
le vôtre pourrait être amené à décliner
un peu la deuxième question concernait
toutes les demandes que vous avez sur le
thème du patrimoine naturel
j'imagine que c'est un signe d'état vous
avez fait référence au fait que ce
serait un des gros dossiers que vous
auriez à traiter dans les prochaines
années et je voulais savoir si vous
aviez des des explications pour
lesquelles vous avez tant de demandes
sur ce patrimoine et quelle était la
manière dont vous alliez l'aborder pour
les prochaines années et enfin je
voudrais dire juste que j'avais
l'impression que vous avez fait
référence au bateau un peu mais j'ai
l'impression que la France est quand
même une grande terre de maritime et que
le patrimoine maritime et fluvial est un
peu le parent pauvre du patrimoine et
qu'il est peut-être un peu plus méconnu
donc je voulais savoir s'il y a votre
connaissance le mécénat d'entreprise
notamment était une aide pour ce
patrimoine et les petites collectes
également vous avez dit à juste titre
que il est intéressant de souligner que
il fallait que le patrimoine est un
usage aussi et le patrimoine donc
maritime les bateaux les vieux gréements
ont cet usage vous savez aussi que cette
année ce sont les 100 ans du marithé qui
est très associé à l'histoire maritime
de la France c'est un beau un bel
anniversaire et je dis ça parce que
c'est peut-être moins connu que les
châteaux que les maisons que tout le
patrimoine auquel on fait référence
d'habitude et d'ailleurs vous avez un
membre éminent de votre fondation qui
siège à la Fondation pour le patrimoine
maritime et fluvial créé par Gérard
Daboville que vous connaissez bien je
crois donc je voulais savoir si vous
pensiez que voilà ce patrimoine était
assez pris en compte merci beaucoup
[Musique]
merci merci monsieur le Président merci
Madame récré général je voudrais revenir
sur notre dame dans vos propos vous ne
citez pas le rapport de la Cour des
comptes il me semble que le rapport de
la Cour des comptes aimait plutôt un
avis positif sur la façon dont les
travaux ont été menés financé et prévu
même si le fait quelques remarques et je
voudrais savoir s'il faut comprendre de
votre interrogation si vous souhaitiez
garder le surplus et auquel cas il faut
tout de suite nous dire ce qu'il en est
et pourquoi parce que c'est ce que j'ai
cru comprendre à travers vos propos mais
sans doute sans doute me suis-je sans
doute et je mal interprété ce que ce que
vous avez dit puisque
ce que dit la Cour des comptes c'est que
quand même dans un contexte qui est
devenu inflationniste il risque y avoir
de nouveau surcoût que par ailleurs il
peut y avoir encore des aléas que par
ailleurs il peut y avoir encore des
difficultés dans les chantiers
éventuelles et que donc aujourd'hui
c'est révalué à 552 millions mais avant
la fin des chantiers et que cette
évaluation à 55 millions d'euros doit
d'ailleurs être refaite et c'est ce que
demande et également la cour et ensuite
elle dit que pour le reste tout l'argent
doit être gardé pour les les travaux et
en effet avec un accord des mécènes et
en précisant que l'État pourrait
s'inspirer de la convention existante
pour les travaux de restauration
antérieure à l'incendie parce que la
Cour dit bien que il est légitime que
une partie des financements puisse aussi
financer enfin pardon des décrédients
puissent aussi financer ceux qui
correspond à des travaux liés à la
situation antérieure à l'incendie donc
j'aimerais c'est ce qui est écrit dans
le rapport de la Cour malgré le
haussement de tête de notre président de
commission j'aimerais savoir quel est
votre appréciation sur les différents
éléments qui qui figurent dans le
rapport de la Cour des comptes à propos
de Notre-Dame et notamment ses aspects
là
[Musique]
Alexandra borcher au fond de teint
vos interventions respectives qu'en
permis bien sûr de réaffirmer le rôle
crucial de la Fondation dans la
préservation de notre patrimoine mais
surtout nous dresser finalement un
panorama des actions menées des enjeux
auxquels la fondation doit faire face
vous le savez mieux que quiconque
[Musique]
tout à l'heure notamment
de Madame vantalon et Monsieur ozoulias
a pointé justement le risque important
de cette dégradation accélérée de notre
patrimoine religieux alors je me réjouis
du succès de la mission sauvegarde du
patrimoine qui permet de financer de
nouveaux travaux de restauration et je
peux le constater dans mon département
notamment avec la tour du ministère de
l'île Saint-Honorat à Cannes qui ont
bénéficié j'ai bien noté dans ce cadre
d'ailleurs que l'auto du patrimoine
devait être devrait être prolongée pour
au moins 5 ans alors est-ce vraiment
suffisant alors qu'entre 2500 et 5000
églises pourraient tout bonnement
disparaître en France d'ici 2030
avez-vous des propositions
complémentaires nos apportés afin de
préserver notre patrimoine
culturel et culturel d'un délitement
certain et puis j'ai une autre
interrogation j'aimerais revenir sur la
fiscalité il est primordial que nous
mettions tout en oeuvre que nous
mettions en oeuvre en tout cas tous les
moyens possibles pour préserver notre
patrimoine alors malgré la bonne volonté
de nos
concitoyens comme d'ailleurs dans mon
département dans une commune il y a des
bénévoles qui sont mobilisés pour
rénover eux-mêmes une forteresse à
l'abandon depuis 200 ans nous allons
donc laisser périr notre patrimoine
historique si on prend pas des mesures
supplémentaires plus fortes le recours
au mécénat s'avère être à mon sens un
levier intéressant qu'il ne faut pas
hésiter à encourager alors sans remettre
en cause l'intérêt réel de ces mécènes
et de ses parents pour notre patrimoine
on peut supposer que les avantages
fiscaux découlent de qui découlent de
ces dons ont un effet incitatif majeur
pensez-vous donc par conséquent
qu'augmenter ou développer des
incitations fiscales créer un cercle
qu'on pourrait qualifier de vertueux qui
augmenterait le nombre de dons ce qui
contribuerait bien sûr à grandement à la
préservation de notre patrimoine je vous
remercie
Olivier Pacaud
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Président Madame la Directrice Générale
merci pour votre présentation j'étais
très impressionné par les chiffres que
vous avez donné
on s'est tous ici l'ampleur du travail
de la Fondation du Patrimoine sur tout
le tout le pays mais j'avoue que les
chiffres m'ont totalement surpris
j'ai comprendre qu'il y avait eu 18000
projets en tout pratiquement depuis
1985000 35000 35000 alors autant pour
moi
dans 18000 communes c'est-à-dire une
commune sur deux
dans le prolongement de la réflexion de
de notre ami Pierre ouzouillas moi j'ai
envie de vous interroger sur la
problématique que vous avez évoqué sur
le fait que
selon vous la préservation la survie la
renaissance de notre patrimoine passe
par son utilisation en quelque sorte
parfois même une renaissance et vous
évoquez
la nécessité de
d'une évolution des usages
alors pour parler de football parce que
vous avez parlé un petit peu de football
et je sais que ça plaît à mon ami
Hugonnet le dépassement de fonction en
quelque sorte
et c'est vrai que transformer une église
une chapelle alors vous avez utilisé le
salle des fêtes alors ça peut être
effectivement des salles des fêtes ça
peut être des bibliothèques passer du
culture elle aux cultural on a beaucoup
de beaux exemples comme ça et moi ma
question elle est un peu psychologique
est-ce que vous avez noté chez les
partenaires locaux que que la Fondation
du patrimoine
doit enfin avec qui elle doit nouer des
partenariats est-ce que vous avez pu
noter parfois une évolution des
mentalités c'est à dire que pendant
longtemps il y a environ 30 ans une
église ça devait rester une église dans
l'esprit de certains et c'était trahir
entre guillemets ça ça fonction
originale originelle plutôt que de
l'affaire évoluer j'ai l'impression en
tout cas dans mon département de l'Oise
où on a de très beaux exemples
d'évolution comme ça des fonctions j'ai
l'impression que je sais pas si ça se
décoince mais que il y a une évolution
des mentalités moi je m'en félicite et
je voulais vraiment avoir votre point de
vue là-dessus
oui merci monsieur le Président bon
monsieur le Président Madame la
Directrice moi je m'associe concerne
louange sur votre action et d'ailleurs
il y a une telle harmonie dans notre
commission que finalement les questions
déjà été posées moi je voudrais
simplement
réagir à deux de vos remarques la
première c'est effectivement la collecte
pour
Notre-Dame j'ai entendu ce que vous avez
dit je crois que tous les gens les les
mécènes tous les gens qui ont apporté
souhaitent que le bâtiment soit bien sûr
reconstruit mais il souhaite aussi qu'il
puisse être visité et que vous
interveniez
dans dans les dispositifs de sortie
secours ça me choque pas ça me paraît
même plus vertueux que déplacer vos
collègues sur
sur des sur un patrimoine qui serait pas
fléchés de cette façon donc ça je
voulais vous le dire la deuxième chose
aussi réagir sur le mécénat messena des
grandes entreprises qui est limité je
trouve normal aussi limite le reste
c'est c'est de l'impôt et c'est pas un
mécénat mais c'est une solidarité qui
est aussi importante rien n'empêche les
gens d'ailleurs de faire du vrai mécénat
mais qui soit pas à ce moment-là
subventionné par l'État pour aller plus
loin donc c'est pour ça que la remarque
je
trouve que c'est bien qu'on puisse
l'encourager l'aider mais c'est pas
choquant qui puisse y avoir une une
limite comme vous l'avez signalé voilà
Marie-Pierre Monnier
merci monsieur le président
je vous remercie pour votre présentation
de la Fondation c'est très intéressant
j'aurai quelques questions est-ce que
vous constatez aujourd'hui une
répercussion de la conjoncture sur le
montant des dons que vous percevez alors
il me semble que je vous avais rencontré
que j'avais pu vous rencontrer un
audition dans la Commission en 2019 et à
l'époque vous nous aviez alerté sur la
concurrence montante des plateformes de
crowdfunding est-ce que vous pouvez nous
parler de l'évolution de ce phénomène et
puis nous avions aussi échangé sur votre
souhait d'étendre votre réseau de
bénévoles alors tout à l'heure je l'ai
entendu au lieu de 500 à l'époque nous
aviez dit vous êtes à 850 mais de le
rajeunir et de le féminiser qu'en est-il
aujourd'hui et en fin de deux petites
questions sur la proposition de loi qui
visait à moderniser les outils la
gouverneur de la fondation de patrimoine
l'article premier visait à éteindre à 20
000 habitants le seuil d'attribution du
label de la Fondation du patrimoine qui
était jusque la limitée aux communes
rurales le Sénat à l'époque avait
introduit quelques précisions à cette
extension afin de garantir que le
patrimoine rural reste au cœur de
l'action de la Fondation du Patrimoine
qu'en est-il aujourd'hui est-ce que vous
auriez par hasard le pourcentage de vos
projets financés qui s'inscrivent dans
ce cadre élargi
et est-ce que ce cette élargissement a
conduit à une tension sur vos ressources
financières elles ne concurrence accrue
entre les projets je vous remercie enfin
dernière question Jean agréé
bien merci monsieur le Président cher
Laurent monsieur le Président Madame la
Directrice générale j'ai différentes
questions à vous poser c'est vrai que
l'excellent rapport d'un pantalon et
Pierre bouzouillas a été cité à demain
de reprise mais je voudrais citer celui
de Sabine rexeler et sa proposition
concernant la création d'un référent du
patrimoine au ministère de l'écologie
c'est une proposition qui avait fait
l'unanimité il y a une quinzaine de
jours dans cette commission qu'en
pensez-vous c'est vrai que notre
collègue Olivier Pacaud souligné le fait
que parfois il faut avoir des évolutions
psychologiques qu'est-ce qu'on ne
pourrait pas amener une évolution
psychologique au sein du ministère pour
aider les classes moyennes et populaires
à rénover le patrimoine bâti dans nos
communes
l'utilisation de l'argent de Notre-Dame
ça a été évoqué par Julien barjetton il
y a quelques instants que comptez-vous
faire de cet argent comptez-vous leur
investir dans du patrimoine plutôt dans
nos territoires ou pourrait-on aussi
l'utiliser pour le centre de formation
que nous avons dans nos territoires je
pense notamment au tailleur de pierre
j'ai un centre de formation dans ma
commune donc il faut toujours faire la
promotion de son territoire ou alors
peut-être même tout ce qui est
toiture charpente les formations de
charpentier et d'hiver c'est
deux autres questions vous avez parlé de
protéger la faune et la force replanter
la forêt comment s'inscrit l'action de
la Fondation du Patrimoine dans la
perspective des annonces
gouvernementales avec la planification
écologique comment peut-on bénéficier à
la Fondation du Patrimoine de la volonté
du gouvernement de replanter de
replanter la forêt et comment s'inscrire
votre action dans ce plan et avez-vous
fait dernière question une estimation du
déplafonnement suite à votre proposition
en introduction du déplafonnement des 2
millions d'euros de dons par les
fondations combien d'argent cela
pourrait vous apporter si par exemple
nous mettions non pas 2 millions d'euros
mais 3 millions d'euros de
déplafonnement je vous remercie
beaucoup de questions alors je vais
commencer par Notre Dame parce que c'est
le sujet d'actualité qui a l'air de
préoccuper de nombreux sénateurs ici
tout d'abord je voudrais lever une
ambiguïté cet argent de Notre-Dame de la
collecte ne vous appartient pas et
n'appartient pas non plus à la Fondation
du Patrimoine donc quand vous dites vous
voulez utiliser cet argent pour autre
chose ou pour vos projets etc j'aurais
tout de suite cet argent aujourd'hui
l'argent d'une donation l'argent d'un
mécénat qui a fait l'objet d'un contrat
il a un objet et cet objet une
destination très précise et cet objet
est protégé par la Constitution
et donc c'est un espèce de démembrement
de sa propriété et donc la question de
savoir si oui ou non on doit financer
les sorties de secours de la crypte avec
l'argent de la reconstruction de
Notre-Dame on peut toujours en discuter
ici pendant des heures et des heures etc
c'est pas nous qu'avons la réponse c'est
les grands mécènes est-ce qu'ils veulent
oui ou non cette extension
mais attention il faut que les choses
soient claires et c'est ça le sujet de
notre débat aujourd'hui avec
l'établissement public c'est d'avoir une
véritable césure entre ce qui relève de
l'objet de la collecte
rebâtir Notre-Dame selon le président de
la République rebâtir Notre-Dame repas
dire Notre-Dame excusez-moi c'est pas
l'issue de secours de la sacristie donc
c'est pas le mobilier donc rebâtir
Notre-Dame et puis ce qui peut relever
des accessoires et moi j'ai rien contre
je ne dis au général je ne serai pas
choqué qu'on aille demander à nos
mécènes une extension sur sur ses
collègues et que cet argent reste à
notre âme mais encore faut-il c'est ce
que propose la cour leur demander mais
pour leur demander il faut avoir de la
transparence monsieur le sénateur si je
ne suis pas capable de faire la
différence et si l'établissement public
me dit tout est dans tout parce que vous
comprenez il y aurait peut-être un petit
peu de plomb qui serait peut-être ce qui
serait peut-être infiltré en dessous
dans la sacristie et puis le plan sont
absolument partout et donc on va tout
refaire bon là j'ai un petit sujet il
faut savoir que le respect de l'objet de
la collecte c'est l'alpha et l'oméga du
lien philanthropique
et si demain nous avions un nouveau
drame et que nous appelions nous
Fondation du Patrimoine a une grande
collecte je peux vous dire que il
vaudrait mieux qu'on puisse être en
mesure de démontrer que dans le passé
les collectes ont été impeccablement
utilisés au millimètre au millimètre
exactement en rapport avec l'objet de la
collecte et très honnêtement quand j'en
parle à la ministre et quand j'en parle
au président de la République je pense
que il ne s'oppose pas à cette idée donc
il s'agit pas de dérouter de l'argent de
Notre-Dame pour aller faire autre chose
ça il s'agit un d'avoir de la
clairvoyance deuxièmement il s'agit de
savoir qui est responsable de quoi pour
la cathédrale Notre-Dame je l'ai dit
tout à l'heure il ne je il est
inconcevable que l'incendie de
Notre-Dame soit une aubaine pour les
finances publiques
alors sinon on va mettre le feu à tout
si à chaque fois qu'on va finir par
mettre le feu à tout notre patrimoine
c'est inconcevable donc les fameux 60
millions d'euros que l'État avait prévu
d'investir dans la cathédrale
antérieurement à l'incendie il est
impensable que ces 60 millions d'euros
disparaissent on peut pas dire je peux
pas dire à mes messages bonjour vous
allez sur soulager le budget qui était
prévu de Bercy c'était un contrat entre
la Fondation Notre-Dame et le ministère
on ne peut pas aujourd'hui passer ça en
perte et profits en disant bonjour bah
finalement en fait un truc donc l'État
doit faire son boulot et puis ensuite
derrière il y aura des recettes à la
cathédrale comme vous le savez puisqu'il
y a des recettes de il y a de la
billetterie assez importante pour
visiter la sacristie pour visiter la
tour c'est le CMN qui est amené ses
recettes tout à fait estimer que le CMN
qui va bénéficier des futurs recettes
puissent payer excusez-moi les sorties
de secours de la tour enfin
il faut un moment donné être honnête
c'est du bon sens excusez-moi quoi et je
pensais pas de voir ici le justifier
alors ça c'est ça c'est pour Notre-Dame
et ça c'est ça c'est pour ça c'est pour
notre Dame bon sur sur les autres sujets
alors peut-être sur un petit mot sur les
coeurs de ville rapidement sur les cœurs
de ville et les petites et les petites
villes et notre rôle vis-à-vis de un
effet ce sujet des bâtiments
patrimoine l'action pour le patrimoine
et c'est une action du secteur culture
mais il y a bien d'autres en réalité
thématique qui s'y raccrochent et
le programme petite ville de demain avec
son cœur de ville ils peuvent contribuer
donc la Fondation du Patrimoine est
devenue partenaire de ces programmes
pourquoi parce qu'on constate que en
fait dans un certain nombre de localités
qui sont plus des villages mais qui sont
des petites villes ou des Bours on a des
problématiques patrimoniales qui sont
vraiment intenses parfois des situations
de déshérence ou de vacances qui sont
qui sont très accentuer il y a des lieux
que j'ai visités comme viviers voilà
c'est des petites villes qui sont de
très grandes qualités mais dans un état
catastrophique donc il y a vraiment des
programmes adoc à monter pour ces lieux
qui pourront peut-être dans 20 ou 25 ans
devenir des zones touristiques comme on
l'a vu en d'autres endroits
de petites villes et de villages qui ont
vraiment été au fil du temps c'est un
effort patient et nous on est tout à
fait prêt à y contribuer alors vous avez
pointé madame la sénatrice la difficulté
des porteurs de projets que sont les
élus des petites communes ou les
propriétaires privés à naviguer parmi
les aides donc ça c'est une réalité
qu'on connaît bien Guillaume prescrina
et moi-même nous avions beaucoup
réfléchi dans le passé au sujet de la
simplification et de la Réforme de
l'État donc les solutions de guichet
unique c'est des solutions intéressantes
il faut percevoir aussi qu'elles sont
toujours très longues à mettre en oeuvre
puisque elles viennent lutter contre un
certain nombre de périmètres ou de près
carré il faut que les différents niveaux
de collectivité s'entendent donc c'est
pas toujours facile à mettre en œuvre et
je crois que ce que nous on essaie de
faire immédiatement c'est un accompagné
les élus avec nos bénévoles avec nos
salariés on a créé un outil récemment
d'ailleurs dans le cadre du programme
petite ville de main qui s'appelle le
portail du patrimoine où on présente de
manière informative assez claire non
bureaucratique les acteurs les aides à
qui s'adresser pas que la Fondation du
Patrimoine mais aussi l'état l'Europe
les régions les autres associations les
autres fondations donc pour pour aider
tout un chacun à naviguer ce ces
différents parcours du patrimoine puis a
sans doute un défi à adresser dans le
futur c'est la question du coût des
travaux la maîtrise des dépenses d'une
certaine manière ce que l'on voit sur
les grands chantiers se réplique au
niveau des petits c'est comment aider
les élus à faire la qualité les travaux
qui convient pour le prix qui convient
et dans certains cas quand on a des
grands chantiers oui on peut recommander
même financer des solutions d'assistance
à maîtrise d'ouvrage ça veut dire que le
maître d'ouvrage à côté de lui un
professionnel qui va négocier avec les
architectes et avec les entreprises
pour les tout petits chantiers ça les ça
n'a pas forcément aujourd'hui de
rationalité donc il faut qu'il faudra
trouver
une structure qui va qui va jouer ce
rôle donc on peut développer nos
ressources de bénévolat et on peut
travailler avec les acteurs comme les
CAE il y a beaucoup de partenariats au
niveau national et puis de relations au
niveau local mais c'est vrai que c'est
un problème à construire qui nous a été
fréquemment remontés et nous en tant que
fondation on peut pas seulement se
satisfaire de voir l'addition
et d'essayer de la financer de boucher
les trous de ce qui n'est pas rafinancer
il faudrait avoir une réflexion sur la
capacité à faire des travaux à coût
maîtriser
et quels sont les instruments pour ça
pour les mettre d'ouvrages qui sont des
petites communes
alors quelques mots sur les monuments
historiques puis de carbone oui moi je
suis bénévole à la Fondation du
Patrimoine donc mon métier c'est d'être
promoteur immobilier bas carbone donc je
fabrique des bâtiments en bois je
connais je connais l'intérêt en effet de
stocker du carbone dans le dans les
matériaux biosourcés issus de la
photosynthèse vous savez que les arbres
c'est rien de plus simple pour des
intoxiquer la planète que de faire
pousser les arbres encore faut-il les
protéger et donc nos poutres nos
charpentes sont des puits de carbone et
évidemment on a tout intérêt à les
garder d'autant plus que comme vous le
savez dans l'acte de construire 60% des
émissions si on est à la construction
donc si on dit aux gens vous ne pouvez
plus habiter dans votre village parce
qu'on est incapable vous devez aller
habiter en pavillon à côté alors là je
peux vous dire que du point de vue du
bilan on aura tout faux parce que ça
veut dire d'abord reconstruire donc ça
veut dire des nouveaux matériaux de
construction ça veut dire beaucoup
d'émissions et puis ça veut dire ensuite
après des transports en automobile donc
voilà c'est c'est de toute façon du
point de vue de l'empreinte carbone
globale on aura toujours un intérêt à
rénover nos villages nos centres-villes
dans le respect du patrimoine et à ce
qui est de la vie à l'intérieur de ces
bâtiments et on imagine pas voilà que
que que
nos bâtiments se détériorent et que nos
villages se vident donc il faut trouver
les solutions bien sûr il faut se
mobiliser pour trouver les solutions le
le label on est peut-être et peut-être
un des outils qui vont permettre qui
vont permettre de sauver ce patrimoine
et de le rendre déficient du point de
vue climatique
tout en le en le préservant et en
évitant sa destruction en fait et son
remplacement
pour réagir à votre question je vais
essayer qu'on a bien perçu aussi ce
problème de prise de conscience
finalement de l'impact énergétique
positif du bâtiment patrimonial en tout
cas en ce qui concerne la phase de
travaux puisque les travaux sur le
patrimoine c'est avant tout de la main
d'oeuvre c'est beaucoup moins de
matériaux puis on garde un bâtiment
existant et donc on est en train de
réaliser une étude d'impact
environnemental qui va permettre de
mesurer objectivement à partir d'un
certain nombre de cas concrets quel est
l'impact carbone quel est l'impact
écologique de la restauration
patrimoniale on tiendra compte aussi des
émissions du bâtiment alors évidemment
c'est différent si le bâtiment a été
rénové pour être
moins énergivore ou pas et ça nous
permettra d'objectiver ce constat de le
partager et de diffuser cette prise de
conscience de l'intérêt des bâtiments
patrimoniaux donc cette étude elle
devrait être disponible au cours de
l'année 2023 évidemment on sera heureux
de vous la partager sur la question du
crowdfunding et puis des startups qu'on
a vu arriver en effet il y a quelques il
y a quelques années
moi et à la Fondation avec mes mes
collègues du bureau on a horreur du
mélange des genres c'est à dire qu'on a
horreur qu'il y a des gens qui se disent
philanthrope et qui en fait monde des
business autour de la philanthropie
c'est quelque chose qui me donne de
l'urticaire à titre personnel moi je
suis bénévole Fondation du Patrimoine et
la philanthropie elle doit pas être à
l'origine d'enrichissement de projets de
startups financé par des business angels
avec des retours sur investissement
considérables voilà alors donc il y
avait des gens qui en effet ce sont dit
finalement il y a plusieurs milliards
d'euros chaque année qui quittent les
poches des Français pour aller vers des
œuvres pourquoi est-ce qu'on se mettrait
pas entre les deux pour désintermédiés
tout ça et finalement on va prendre 5%
et 5% de plusieurs milliards ça finit
par faire beaucoup d'argent donc voilà
on s'est émus de cela Dieu merci ça n'a
pas prospéré ça n'a pas prospéré parce
que je pense qu'au bout d'un certain
temps les gens sont pas dupe ils savent
qu'en fait ils donnent à des entreprises
privées et que la philanthropie telle
qu'elle est sa sincérité
voilà et depuis 5 ans avec Célia nous
sommes dans une promotion active de nos
cadres féminins donc en Alsace nous
avons une femme Provence à la Côte
d'Azur nous avons une femme pour diriger
tout ça et nous en sommes absolument
ravis et nous essayons aussi de rajeunir
nos
ayons que nous soyons représentative de
la société et pas d'un seul segment
aussi honorable soit-il j'ai pas mais
mais vu mes vieux patrons de banque
régionale de caisse régionale de tel et
telle institution ils sont formidables
ils sont très dynamiques etc mais il
faut que nous arrivions à les mélanger
avec des jeunes avec des jeunes actifs
voilà et avec tout ce qui représentent
la force parce que finalement c'est
cette
réappropriation du patrimoine qui peut
sauver le patrimoine c'est pas c'est pas
Paris qui va sauver c'est pas nous tous
ensemble malgré notre énergie notre
capacité de mécénat c'est véritablement
dans les villages que on peut retrouver
la solution je continue très vite et
sans sur le patrimoine religieux le
patrimoine religieux oui on observe une
grande mutation alors le patrimoine
religieux vous connaissez le
l'origine du problème il a eu lieu
probablement dans ses murs en 1905 la
séparation de l'Église et de l'État et
finalement on se retrouve avec des
affectateurs c'est-à-dire le culte qui
nous dit finalement l'entretien de
l'église c'est pas moi l'entretien de
l'église c'est Monsieur le Maire et on
va voir Monsieur le Maire et Monsieur le
Maire nous dit on est absolument désolé
mais il y a 12 fidèles à la messe le
dimanche et la messe n'a lieu d'ailleurs
que plus que une fois tous les tous les
mois et donc je suis désolé mais mais
mes ressources sont contraintes je vais
là où il y a de l'intérêt je suis obligé
de compte de faire de quelque part de
regarder les priorités etc et donc en
fait on se retrouve dans un vide
sur les églises on se retrouve dans un
vide et si nous on a 1000 églises
aujourd'hui dans le grand hôpital que je
vous décrivais à travers la France donc
1000 et grises en souscription c'est
parce qu'on est dans un vide et ce vide
en fait pour réconcilier les choses
parce que nous on n'est pas là pour
faire de la polémique on est là pour
réconcilier les énergies autour du
patrimoine il se fait en effet au jour
aujourd'hui autour de la discussion sur
le partage des usages dans le respect du
culte donc la plupart du temps quand
nous intervenons sur des églises
d'ailleurs et sont des affectées je le
dis très directement parfois elles sont
désaffectifs puis assez longtemps pour
les églises sur lequel il y a le sujet
du partage d'usage c'est elles sont des
affectés évidemment nous intervenons sur
des églises qui elles fonctionnent sur
avec des collectes pour essayer de de
les sauver donc et je pense que la
France est beaucoup plus ouverte
qu'avant on a un travail avec Bertrand
de Feydeau notre vice-président sur ce
sujet justement de l'avenir du du
patrimoine religieux lui-même était
secrétaire du cardinal du stigé à je
vais chez de Paris donc il connaît bien
cette univers et avec un groupe de
travail il est en train de d'essayer de
voir comment est-ce qu'on peut mettre en
oeuvre en fait ces opérations de
sauvetage et de réaffectation d'usage il
me faut encore ça s'adresse pas à tout
le patrimoine religieux
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce qu'on a raté
ouais vas-y ah oui oui avec les
donc sur le la question des délais
d'intervention des APF sur les labels
alors d'une part c'est vrai que la
nouvelle loi qui était adoptée suite à
une initiative de la sénatrice à Madame
Verrien a permis donc hausser le seuil
des labels ce qui a eu des effets
positifs on en a fait une étude dont on
pourra vous transmettre tous les détails
puisque il y a une croissance de nom de
la belle donc on volume les labels dans
les zones rurales n'ont pas diminué non
pas été vampirisés par des labels dans
les petits bourgs
mais il y a une croissance générale
relativement maîtrisée mais positive ce
qui fait qu'aujourd'hui dans les
communes de 2000 à 20000 habitants c'est
à peu près 14% de nos labels
mais ce sont des labels en plus voilà
donc
la norme que d'ailleurs le Sénat avait
fixé sur le fait que au moins 50% de nos
labels doivent être en zone rural et
parfaitement respecté on est bien au
dessus on est à 70% aujourd'hui donc on
rase prioritairement dans les zones
rurales mais on ouvre une possibilité
nouvelle dans les petits bourgs ce qui
est très vertueux dans des villes de
type petite ville de demain ou autre
avec lesquelles on fait des partenariats
pour avoir une action donc un peu plus
systématique alors évidemment oui ça va
créer une tension sur nos ressources
puisque comme vous l'avez expliqué
Guillaume Poitrinal quand on délivre un
label on doit donner une aide et dans un
certain nombre de cas on le fait grâce à
des partenariats avec des collectivités
certaines sont très généreuses il y a
beaucoup de départements qui participent
mais ça n'est pas le cas partout et donc
il faut que la Fondation puisse
contribuer elle-même et puis le coût des
travaux se renchérit quand même donc il
faut que nous on mobilise le plus de
fonds on a aussi des collègues de
mécénat non affectés qu'on peut utiliser
pour financer
ses besoins mais il faut avoir
conscience que si on veut développer cet
outil il faudra aussi que la Fondation
et les moyens de pouvoir accorder ses
aides et donc on continue à se tourner
vers les collectivités sources de fond
qui nous sont données alors il y a un
problème de process quand même c'est que
aujourd'hui les propriétaires qui
veulent faire des travaux sont dans une
seringue parce que les entreprises
exigent que les devis soient signés dans
les 15 jours sinon le prix sera inflaté
et les matériaux sont peut-être pas
disponibles or le process administratif
et d'une rapidité inégale il y a bien
des endroits où on arrive à travailler
très très bien avec les ABS parce que
par exemple on se met autour de la table
et on instruit très rapidement les
dossiers que les bénévoles de la
Fondation du Patrimoine ont déjà regardé
et triés et puis d'autres endroits il y
a des processus qui sont plus classiques
donc la BF reçoit le dossier parfois ça
prend quelques mois et aujourd'hui c'est
beaucoup trop long pour les
propriétaires donc on a entamé une
réflexion interne et on adore et déjà
acté avec le ministère de la culture
qu'on a les partager des recommandations
de bonnes pratiques que l'on constate
dans un certain nombre de lieux et qu'on
pourrait étendre au plan national pour
que ça soit plus fluide et aussi qu'on
économise du travail aux ABS qui dans un
centre de cas ils ont déjà vu en fait
les dossiers au titre des autorisations
d'urbanisme dans les secteurs
patrimoniaux remarquables dans les
abords de monuments historiques en fait
les projets de construction et de
rénovation leur ont déjà été soumis donc
il conviendrait en fait à de paralyser
les procédures pour aller plus vite de
se fixer des délais parce que dans
l'urbanisme par exemple il y a des
délais de décision pour le label on en
applique pas il faudrait qu'on
s'applique des délais qu'ils soient
normatifs ou qu'il ne soit pas
et donc être plus efficace et ça c'est
un travail qui est en cours dont on
pourra vous donner les résultats d'ici
quelques mois alors ça nous amène sur
les relations avec le ministère de la
Culture très honnêtement elles sont très
bonnes et elles sont en train d'être
amélioration donc il y a beaucoup moins
ce sentiment que finalement nous étions
nous sommes le petit patrimoine voilà
que le monde le monde des châteaux et le
monde des petites voilà donc avec Rima
Abdul Malak il y a quelque part je pense
échanges qui est en train de se
construire qui est beaucoup plus dans le
détail beaucoup moins dans je pense
l'apparence et le discours et beaucoup
plus terre à terre parce que nous nous
sommes des des une équipe d'actions
notre notre ambition c'est l'action
notre ambition l'ambition de nos
bénévoles c'est de livrer ces inaugurer
ces deux sauver avec des temps qui nous
sont contraints donc il y a clairement
je pense de ce point de vue là en tout
cas il y a il y a rien on va pas venir
se plaindre ici de cette relation elle
est excellente et puis vous avez posé la
question du patrimoine naturel et du
patrimoine maritime c'est très important
pour nous on le développe ça marche très
bien nos collectes fonctionnent très
bien d'ailleurs voilà j'ai un bateau là
où on a déjà récupéré
85%, on a déjà récupéré 279000 euros le
bateau de course croisière yannickaeling
worth mais on en a plein des bateaux
donc si vous allez sur notre site vous
allez trouver des magnifiques vieux
grément il y en a partout il y a qui
vont de la petite barque de perche
Pépito
on essaye de récupérer 10000 euros
jusqu'à des vieux gréements magnifiques
avec deux mains vous pouvez les
découvrir on est tout à fait mobilisé
sur le patrimoine patrimoine naturel oui
pourquoi est-ce qu'on a de plus en plus
de demandes sur le patrimoine naturelle
il y a évidemment une conscience
générale de la nécessité de protéger
notre magnifique patrimoine naturelle
mais il y a surtout il y a aussi et
également l'effet du réchauffement
climatique sur les arbres et donc il
faut replanter la France donc il faut et
replanter la France ça coûte des sous
donc et donc très clairement aujourd'hui
nous sommes à la manœuvre pour pour
essayer de trouver des mécénats sur sur
ces forêts sur et pour répondre aux
enjeux du réchauffement climatique c'est
c'est principalement ce qui nous est
demandé et ce qui nous arrive
aujourd'hui pour compléter sur le
patrimoine naturel
la Fondation du Patrimoine à cette
originalité que dès sa naissance elle a
été créée pour répondre aux enjeux du
patrimoine architectural et du
patrimoine naturel avec une double
tutelle de fondation donc c'est pas une
tutelle d'établissement public mais une
tutelle de fondation du ministère de la
culture et du ministère de l'Écologie et
dans notre histoire on a plus développé
la section patrimoine architecturale
mais la section patrimoine naturelle a
toujours été existante et aujourd'hui ce
qu'on veut c'est traiter les sujets dans
leur globalité parce qu'en fait il y a
pas de césure c'est le monde dans lequel
on vit c'est le cadre de nos villages
donc il faut qu'on puisse aborder la
question de la rénovation écologique du
bâtiment la biodiversité qui se niche
dans les environs il y a des il y a de
la nature aménagée et puis il y a des
espaces qui sont protégés au titre du
code de l'environnement mais tout ça
c'est une continuité et le patrimoine
naturel il voyage il n'est pas statique
donc il est très important que qu'on
puisse traiter tout ça et comme le Diggy
on Poitrinal il y a une formidable
capacité à lever du mécénat et des dons
puisque c'est un sujet qui est beaucoup
les entreprises et aussi nos concitoyens
et du bénévolat donc on a beaucoup de
jeunes qui viennent nous voir en disant
on veut se mobiliser aidez-nous comment
est-ce qu'on peut faire etc et là la
Fondation est tout à fait prête à les
accueillir et et à aider sur sur la
réalisation de ces projets de sauvetage
dernière dernière question peut-être
président sur la baisse des collectes
est-ce qu'on observe une baisse des
collègues la réponse est oui sur les
petites collectes donc là il faut être
très direct la réponse est oui sur les
petites collectes statistiquement nous
avons aujourd'hui une une baisse des
collectes
voilà ben ça va nous obliger à pédaler
plus vite
la panthère rude notre sillon est droit
et on va essayer de aller chercher
encore davantage de moyens partout
partout c'est possible pour aller au
secours de ce magnifique patrimoine
français
merci beaucoup merci monsieur le
Président Madame la Directrice Générale
vous savez qu'ici on est très attentif
au patrimoine et vous ne trouverez
toujours à vos côtés bien sûr pour
défendre ce patrimoine nombreux et
divers y compris naturels comme vous
avez bien insisté merci beaucoup pour le
temps que vous avez consacré à répondre
à chacune de nos questions deux éléments
d'information avant de clore cette
commission d'abord pour dire que nous
recevrons le général Georges lin le 18
janvier donc vous avez ouvert un champ
de questions que nous manquerons pas de
de reposer le général
et puis deuxième élément d'information
la tribune que beaucoup d'entre vous ont
consigné paraît aujourd'hui dans le
monde en version numérique et en version
papier également voilà
[Musique]